what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and it's about time for me to
make a new video on how strong is ton
zero since he's clearly gotten a power
boost since the fight against upper moon
three Icaza if you enjoyed these Demon
Slayer videos and want to keep them
coming
make sure to smash that like button and
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss new Demon Slayer videos for more
demons their content and to help me
decide what videos I make in the future
make sure to follow my instagram at
anime uproar i want to also give a huge
thank you to our glorious patrons over
on patreon who helped us survive YouTube
issues and who make videos like this one
possible thank you all so much I'll talk
more about the patrons at the end of the
video for the time being keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers in this
video we have to look at all the latest
evidence to determine exactly how strong
Tundra has become now without further
ado let's jump into it we won't go over
Tundras growth and power from the
beginning of the series to now you can
get a better overview of watching the
old how strong is Tundra video in this
one we will look at how strong he was
against akasa and compare that to how
strong he is now during his seemingly
final battle against Musa when he first
saw Octus a ton zero was useless against
him because he was a injured and be not
strong enough to make a difference then
goku actually had to save his life when
arkansas was about to punch dodge road
to death then goku sacrificed his life
and ended up saving everyone present
from Icaza including tangier oh he knows
k pointed out the situation they were
all in if any of them tried to help in
Goku they would have only gotten in the
way
after 10 Goku died times you know cried
because he felt like he was still so far
behind and couldn't be useful he
wondered if he would ever become
anything like than Goku fast forward to
when a much stronger Tundra took on
Icaza along with gives help by this
point Tundra had not only become
something like than Goku he even
accomplished what then Goku couldn't
while GU was helpless against doctors ax
and had his sword broken by a single
punch
taro got a huge upgrade he had
previously gained access to the
see-through world aka the transparent
world where ty
passes slowly and fast movements look
slow giving the user more time to dodge
or land an attack tundra also unlocked
the selfless state during this fight
where he let go of his fighting spirit
hatred and killing intent in this state
he could cut off a causes hand without a
Kasai even noticing tundra saved you and
in a way redeemed himself for when he
couldn't save it in Goku when he saw it
a Kazakh could tell right away how
strong this selfless state is every
fiber of his being down to each strand
of hair told him to kill tundra right
away
he used an Opie final form move that
launched countless blows in a short
window of time GU an experienced pillar
was hit by a hundred blows all at once
and yet tanja dog was unfazed by the
attack he could have even snuck up on
Icaza who couldn't sense him because of
his lack of fighting spirit but he chose
not to he straight-up told him that he
was going to cut off his head aqus on
you he was coming he saw him coming and
yet he could not prevent tundra from
cutting his head off a feat that then
Goku couldn't even accomplish even a
Kasai admitted that tundra grasped
something that surpassed his own speed
because I called this the domain of
supremacy that he had been seeking for
most of his life everyone who thinks
that tundra just got him because I cuz I
couldn't sense his fighting spirit is
oversimplifying the matter
tanja role was clearly faster and he
attained a level of skill that Icaza
himself admitted that he could never
reach in this moment Tundra surpassed
Icaza however after he caught off his
head Tundra reached his limit and passed
out later when he woke up he didn't even
have enough strength to grip a sword
Arcas admitted that the fight was over
the moment his head was cut off he
admitted that he suffered total defeat
still though arkla if he wanted to could
have regenerated and killed a weak
Tundra egg you even if tundra was
stronger at his best
then Icaza was at his best after this
battle it was clear that Tundra had
achieved a new level of power that was
at its peak stronger than GU and then
Goku however it seemed to have
weaknesses it seemed to only last for a
short period of time for that reason I
was still hesitant
time job of the stronger pillars like
sauna me and Guillaume a because they
can fight at an extremely high level for
a long period of time without their body
giving out now let's jump to when tundra
initially faced off against Musa that
was a very anticlimactic moment time
sure couldn't keep up with the pillars
he got hit in the right eye and he had
trouble maintaining his breathing he hit
into a wall and was about to be taken
out by Musa
before eager to save him you could have
even told him to stay back because he
was a troublesome encumbrance a bit
later Tundra passed out because mulan's
flesh-eating poison had spread
throughout his body he didn't even
really get a chance to enter the
see-through world or his selfless state
if we only had this to go off of it
would be impossible to put Tundra above
the strongest pillars however during his
sleep time Joe got an upgrade he gained
access to the memories of his ancestor
and in the process he saw you on Ichi
the strongest Demon Slayer and the first
user of the breadth of the Sun in action
Tundra is your Ichi successor in the
dance of the fire God was his family his
way of passing down the strongest breath
the breath of the Sun time just saw all
12 forms performed by your Ichi
and that helped him a lot he realized
that he had wasteful movements the angle
of his wrist was off his footwork was
off and he didn't know the proper
intervals between breaths in other words
his version of the breath of the Sun was
flawed even though it was strong enough
to temporarily overpower Icaza there was
a lot of room for improvement through
the memories Tundra learned a proper
method his biggest flaw was that he
couldn't fight at his best for long and
after waking up he figured out how his
father was able to dance until dawn he
figured out how to breathe properly so
that like his dad said he could
theoretically dance
aka fight forever remember Tundras dad
was sick and yet he was able to dance
until dawn by breathing properly
similarly now Tundra should be able to
fight moves on until dawn despite how
injured and poison he is tiger also
figured out that the thirteenth form of
son breathing was the twelve forms used
in succession he could keep alternating
between them until dawn and that seems
to be the secret
beating Mouzon when times are initially
woke up he saved canal by cutting off
Milan's arm it was just like when he
saved you by cutting off a causes arm
moves on did not see it coming his arm
also remained cut for a bit rather than
reattaching as it was cut showing that
Mouzon takes longer to regenerate from
Tundras attacks than from most other
peoples and that makes sense since not
only does tundra have a red blade he is
using the strongest breath the breath of
the Sun and as we all know the demons
from Demon Slayer and the Sun are mortal
enemies now in the present tundra is
fighting moves on his strongest is
stronger than it was against Icaza since
he learned to correct the flaws in his
form by watching you teaching and more
importantly he can now keep going he's
learned a way to keep fighting at his
strongest until dawn by using breathing
properly and by alternating between the
twelve forms of sun breathing he can in
theory keep fighting forever as his dad
said it also doesn't hurt that moves on
sees your ichi looking back at him every
time he looks at ton zero his PTSD is
activated and it probably throws moves
on off even more by the end of chapter
192 tan zero is killing it he looks
confident and determined to win Mouzon
was able to defeat yo mace anima gives
any two in auskey and canal when they
were all working together yo may even
lost his left leg and giel lost his
right arm although I couldn't say it
before I can't say it now
contra has become the strongest living
Demon Slayer
he has surpassed the strongest pillars
and even alone he is fighting better
than they were together Tundra admits
that he is still less skilled than you
Ichi and perhaps things will remain that
way since you're DG was clearly more
talented right out too bad compared to
ton zero it seems like the dude had
access to the see-through world and a
selfless state when he was born however
it is plausible that Tundra could
perfect son breathing and hope to become
as powerful as you of Ichi was
eventually chances are whoever can still
fight including net Zuko will help
Tundra do what you need she could not
alone what I could see happening at this
point is that Mouzon will try to use his
exploding flesh
Niek that he used in the past to escape
from your Ichi
tangelo who is not more powerful than
your Ichi could not hope to cut all 1800
pieces of flesh when your EEG could only
cut about 1500
however if Nezha Koh and the available
demon Slayers can assist tun 0 then
together they could surpass your Ichi
the strongest demon ser in history I
could see something like that happening
because Demon Slayer has constantly
promoted the power of teamwork often we
have multiple demon Slayers working
together to defeat one demon even in
this battle so far yes
con zero is fighting alone but he would
not even be alive to fight if it aint
Goku hadn't saved him from Icaza and he
would not be able to fight effectively
if his ancestors hadn't passed down your
ichi son breathing forms even now tundra
has only come this far because he's
gotten so much help from others however
I think he'll get some more help before
the story is through even though a lot
of the demon Slayers look like they're
in bad shape now it's not uncommon in
this series for characters who passed
out to regain consciousness later and
help in the nick of time so I wouldn't
cross off zenny to any nosegay and
definitely not mezu KO from helping out
in the future but yeah as far as the
series goes it seems like it's going to
be ending soon since the protagonist has
already surpassed the other characters
in power and the final battle what the
main villain is taking place whatever
happens this has been an amazing series
but I do hope to see some power upgrade
from Sonny to before it's all wrapped up
I'd hate for its last fighting moment to
be getting wrecked by boson and that is
it for today's video thank you so much
for watching if you did enjoy this video
and want to see more like it make sure
to smash that like button and share this
video with a friend that really helps
the channel out if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss out on new Demon Slayer videos when
they come out for more Demon Slayer
content epic quotes and to help decide
what videos I make in the future make
sure to follow us on Instagram at anime
uproar a special thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Stephan and
Radha a low line item makoto-kun the
world stealers the school bus and Tyson
Kirino and I can't forget our pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King Saul dress fitted Allah beat alpha
do
Anatoli Cassatt Suki angel Cruz team
sparty 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc and Joel
Stanton thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you get support
more by going over to patreon comm
anime op floor and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these epic people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]